sometimes it's the small things that can
really make a big difference for the
planet consider your answer to a simple
question paper or plastic about neither
they've become insidious global
tumbleweeds wreaking havoc on the
environment each year more than 500
billion plastic bags are used worldwide
and because most bags never fully
biodegrade the environment is loaded
with tiny pieces even small particles
can create major problems within large
swathes of the Pacific Ocean there are
more tiny pieces of plastic than food
but there is good news the list of
countries and cities banning plastic
bags is growing and you can be part of
the solution
so listen bag the bags seriously BYOB
bring your own bags to the grocery store
one small step that leads to big change